[Musik]
richtig
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur style it welt
heute gibt es ein ganz schnelles und
ganz einfaches rezept ich werde einen
toblerone cheesecake zubereiten und war
ganz ohne backen und zwar weil sich mein
mann murat den gewünscht hat die
neuesten automobile sind ohne dich
fragen bevor ich die torte gebacken habe
wusste ich nicht dass toblerone mit
honig und mandeln ist ich dachte mir
dabei karamell drin
ja das ist eine honig mandeln oder
richtig cool und zwar ist kommt aus der
schweiz
die affinität schweißen zwischen körpers
der firma monuments glaube ich wie heiß
wurde 10 x aufgekauft auch immer ist es
im klassiker genauigkeit durch hat
manchen special gesehen und war ging's
darum toblerone und dabei ging es darum
wie bringt man die schokolade richtig ab
weist also die meisten machen einfach so
was aber eigentlich macht waren dick
gibt es am gipfel ganz elegant ag auf
jeden fall soll die schokolade die berge
zeigen genau sieht man auf der packung
genau und ich hab ich tun auch weh tun
sie morgen kühlschrank und weist sie ab
und dann gut ist dann genug und weiß ist
von einem ding den ort fischer hefte
jeden fall geht heute nicht um die
schokolade nur indirekt heute geht es um
die torte und ford hier einen noweck
boden mit keksen natürlich auch mit
toblerone drin und obendrüber diese
cheesecake massen und als topping habe
ich natürlich die schokolade zerkleinert
ohne wochen paar mandeln mit honig und
zucker karamellisiert richtig lecker vor
allem sehr einfach falls immer den
hunger auf den richtig leckeren kuchen
oder auf eine torte bekommen hat ich
fange jetzt an mit dem teigboden und
zeigt euch dafür mal diplomaten
für den boden braucht 150 6 4 bezwungen
100 gramm butter einen etwas honig 60
gramm toblerone schokolade und 50 gramm
gemahlene mandeln zuerst einmal nämlich
jetzt die butter da ist keine mikrowelle
haben sich das ganze bei mir einfach im
topf aber ihr könnt bereits in der
mikrowelle habt da auch bei niedriger
wattzahl die butter schmelzen
natürlich nur als bei niedriger stufe
und sobald sie butter geschmolzen ist
gebe ich da gleich wenn der herd dann
wieder aussieht wie schokolade mit rein
und in der zwischenzeit das kann ich
schon mal die kekse zerkleinern und das
mache ich es einfach mit hilfe eines
gefrierbeutel
[Musik]
jetzt einfach eine maus vorstand darüber
rollen und draufhauen einfach nur das
verkleinert werden
[Musik]
hier gibt es jetzt auch gleich den honig
mit dazu der pass geschmacklich sei gut
denn toblerone besteht nicht nur aus
vollmilchschokolade sondern auch auf
mandeln und honig von daher ich dann
hier auch im boden alle komponenten mit
drin
die in der schokolade enthalten sind
jetzt ist alles weg geschmolzen und ich
kann die klicks lässt das zugeben ganze
geht natürlich schneller wenn ihr das
innenressort zubereitet aber auch so
funktioniert es prima und hier kommen
jetzt noch den mangel mit dazu die habe
ich bereits fein gemahlen und jetzt
alles ganz schön verrühren habe ich hier
einen tortenring server kommt eine back
folie drauf und einen bug ring den hab
ich auf 80 zentimeter durchmesser
eingestellt und da kommt jetzt die masse
rein
ihr könnt ihr jetzt entweder auf 18 oder
auch 20 zentimeter einstellen bei 18
wird die torte ein bisschen höher und
bei 20 einfach vom durchmarsch hin
breiter also so wie es gerne haben
möchte dann am besten bis er mit den
fingern verteilen
und dann mit einem glas fest drücken der
not wurden kommt jetzt für etwa 15
minuten ins getriebe sowie der am
schnellsten fest und in der zwischenzeit
könnt ihr euch schon mal die zutaten für
die füllung zeigen die creme brauche ich
200 gramm toblerone 300 milliliter sahne
500 gramm fisch käse im doppel rand
stufe und 15 seiner partei der boden ist
jetzt gut durchgeführt werden kann ich
kurz zur seite stellen
hier habe ich jetzt bereits die
toblerone schokolade eingeschmolzen und
zwar einfach auf einem warmen aber nicht
mehr kochende wasser bat zuerst nehme
ich jetzt die sahne und schlage steigt
mit der kraft seiner fast
[Musik]
fast kam steht noch nicht ganz fest
denn jetzt kommt noch ein frischkäse
dazu den frühere ich ganz kurzen und
bevor ich die kleinen ganz steif röhre
kommt hier an der stelle noch die
geschmolzene schokolade mit rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt die creme auf den
vorbereiteten boden drauf und wird nur
noch glatt gestrichen
[Musik]
so kommt die torte jetzt für etwa ein
bis drei stunden in den kühlschrank und
dann muss ich sie nur noch dekorieren
die torte ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt
jetzt kümmere ich mich um die dekoration
und zeigt euch mal die zutaten für die
deko brauche schon das ram toblerone 50
gramm ganze mandeln zwei esslöffel honig
und einen teelöffel butter ich nehme
zuerst honig und futter und die zutaten
kommen jetzt in eine pfanne
dafür nehme ich eine beschichtete pfanne
und wettanbietern art karamell anderen
beiden trainiert karamellisiert
[Musik]
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die mandeln nehmen und ganz europa
[Musik]
dürften die zwei punkten kurz aufkochen
jetzt kommen die mandel mir damit das
los und werden darin jetzt einfach ein
bisschen karamellisiert
[Musik]
und dirk ist einfach noch ein bisschen
bis sie farbe bekommen haben
[Musik]
debug folie habe ich jetzt schon
entfernt und jetzt kann ich die torte
für aufsehen und den truck ring
entfernen
[Musik]
im netz dekor ist die torte mit dem talk
ohne stücken und auch mit den
karamellisiertem mandeln als oliver
morath ist darfst du probieren
der erfinder hieß übrigens oder
chocolatiers einzig totoblock genauer
und und vor allem mantel nogat heißt ob
italienisch krone unterhaltungskunst
oktober noch mal wissen was eigentlich
die ganze sicher auf toblerone übrigens
immer im flugzeug etwas ständig machen
viele ich hab auch mal ich habe auch
noch freundinnen jetzt auch im flugzeug
gekauft
ich verstehe das nicht weil ich mir
denke doch überall in jedem supermarkt
aber was soll's ich glaube dass dies oft
ist auf jeder party mit dieser toblerone
frage bist du da lastet material los und
ich frage mich warum überhaupt die
schokolade dreieckig geformten klar sind
auch die da gibt's ja aber ich mal muss
man auf die deckung
vielleicht weiß der einer von euch da
noch eine theorie ist nicht einfach ich
musste es probieren
und wo
wirklich genial also auch wenn ich sonst
immer lüge aber diesmal für nicht genial
war also ohne wie porsches im jahr
[Musik]
eigentlich mit schmeckt ihm nicht top
aber auch wie joghurt und mittenrein
wahrscheinlich meint auch ein bisschen
genial
das freut mich wirklich denn woran ist
ein großer kritiker und meistens aber
auch beruflich immer noch mal so eine
verbesserung
ja du hast sanktioniert weiß niemals die
hand die mit seeed immer wenn man so
atmen kann kriegt aber es freut mich
dass es geht diesmal lief alles schmeckt
ihm eigentlich immer nur hat er eben
manchmal noch verbesserungsvorschläge
faktor ist auch im video jedenfalls
jetzt auch lust auf diese karte bekommen
habt dann schon auf meinem blog auf der
liste des doktor dass wir nochmal die
zutaten sind auch gar nicht so viele zu
tragen
woran das geld kommt wird das komplette
tortenstück aufgegeben oder richtlinie
also ehrlich er das freut mich dass auch
cool das eismachen doch ja das machen
wir gerne könnt ihr euch jetzt auch
wünscht und schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
und ich wünsche euch schon mal ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
ich glaube ich denke ich könnte ein
stück haben mich in sicherheit
[Musik]
bildung
die boote therapie